well you don't have to be a republican
but you cannot be a Democrat who is the
guy that came up with that that's good
man we got to Google that uh here is
Tulsi on Rogan again explaining how the
Democrats are ruining America that's
that's the danger of it is the people in
charge of the democratic party whether
they actually hold positions or they
just are influential in a Democratic
party uh have created this cult-like
atmosphere and fomented this fear so
much so that people who are really in a
position to impact this to stand up
against and say hold on guys this is
literally insane and needs to needs to
stop they're too afraid to do so because
of what the ramifications will be
Democratic party that I joined doesn't
exist anymore the party that was
um you know the party of JFK of Dr
Martin Luther King the party of
inclusivity the big tent party that
welcomed and encouraged this Marketplace
of ideas and conversations and people
who held different views the party of uh
you know the championed women and
equality and the rights of people in our
society that party just it doesn't exist
anymore and instead we have a party
that's being led by by people who have
gone insane with this ideological uh
fanaticism and there are a lot of
different issues a lot of different
examples you know the whole issue of of
uh biology and uh the trans issue is
just one of them there are so many
different others you know parents don't
have a you don't have a right to raise
your kids now you don't have a right to
say what they're being taught in schools
now the state the government the the
teachers unions only they have that
right and responsibility they're
undermining families they don't believe
in the rule of laws yeah defund the
police the Supreme in court we don't
agree with them so they're illegitimate
guys that's the chick that's leaving the
party right it's like if she was there
like I think I could turn these guys
around they're listening and they're
good decent people and I enjoy being
with them
maybe more sane centrists would be going
in that direction but that is not what's
happening of course Tulsi is right about
all of those things so she's making a
lot of sense speaking of sense we got a
little more from her is they don't
believe in freedom of speech they don't
believe in Freedom of thought they don't
believe in freedom of religion all they
believe in is you've got to buy into
whatever they're selling at any given
day and and like I said not only it's
not enough to agree you've got to go out
there you've got to march in the parade
you've got to carry the sign you've got
to scream and yell and don't you dare
even think about talking to Republicans
don't don't even think about working
with Republicans because that that
directly undermines their their
Authority
sound familiar sound familiar from some
guy that faced six seven years ago was a
lefty who kept saying hey there's
problems here guys I'm gonna go talk to
some Republicans I'm going to talk to
some conservatives and see what they're
like and then it turns out that they're
not actually like what the machine wants
you to believe that they are like does
that sound a little bit familiar yeah